an interesting poll came out by
Rasmussen that half of Americans
basically believe that the founding
fathers would be disappointed in the way
America has turned out let's look at
some numbers thirty four percent of
Americans believe if the founding
fathers came back today they view
America as a success that's a pretty low
number forty nine percent say the
founding fathers would view the
present-day US as a failure fifty-one
percent of Democrats say failure
sixty-two percent of Republicans say
failure and seventeen percent say they
aren't sure those numbers seem pretty
legit to me I think the founding fathers
would be rolling in their graves right
now if they saw what was going on
America are we a failure in the eyes of
the founding fathers I mean who knows
you know you look at what they had I
mean you know they didn't have plumbing
plumbing they feel they feel good you
know the plumbing is good yeah but some
of the other stuff really sucks
yeah um Jefferson was a good [ __ ] for
what I this is what I've understand yeah
but he had people that were taking it
out yeah yeah yes he had a seat warmer
boy I had that going on me too doors
closed my my but this funny to see a
pure continuation of where we were at
before the show yes that statistic yes
that the Republicans what was it sixty
four percent sixty two percent of which
is interesting right because they're
always angry at people if they don't
love America Oh Barack Obama's not proud
of America why aren't you proud it turns
out more of them aren't proud of America
than anybody and usually the Republicans
usually love this country and why
shouldn't they they pay full price yeah
the point is but so that isn't that kind
of interesting that they they're the
ones who could but they can say that now
because there's a black hate Obama so
right what are they what did they also
say it because well not only is there a
guy not in charge but they feel that
Liberty has been taken you destroyed
especially look at these last two weeks
it's all about liberty for them at
health care yeah a poor people getting
health care is affecting
also on the heels of gay marriage know
these things that just make them royal
and boil yeah you know they're just so
furious yeah all this movement forward
so speaking of gay marriage so certain
things that the founding fathers would
have never imagined like gay rights and
you know equality for women and for
medical marijuana like that would you
think they'd be happy about that if they
were able to really think it through
because they wanted Liberty individual
liberty so even though it didn't happen
in their time do you think things like
equality for gay people those type of
things would make them proud I think the
yes I think if you deconstruct the the
documents that were written they really
echo what's going on in the in the in
those areas and I think those those men
because because they were all men would
look at it and you know maybe initially
would be like wow what the hell is going
on here but they would look at it and
say yeah this is progress this is what
we've written for if you take what we've
written and you move it forward you know
200 some odd years this is where we were
if you take that I'm sure they would be
upset with the convergence of religion
and politics definitely especially
Thomas Jefferson who wrote the Jefferson
Bible which got rid of all the stupid
[ __ ] right that screws up religion right
so yes I would think that they would be
horrified and what happened I think they
would also be horrified at the corporate
money takeover of politics I think they
would be against that they could not
envision the Koch brothers being able
they didn't envision televisions and so
they didn't understand how you can
control the message just with money and
right now the idea that money equals
free speech well some people have more
money so it's not really free is tonight
right so that's a perfect segue to my
next thing because I want to know what
do you guys think they would think about
the Tea Party because the Tea Party's
whole thing was no taxation without
representation which goes to the to the
money issue they obviously believed in
that but I don't I don't really think
they would buy into a lot of the Tea
Party stuff now would they I can't see
it these people are just like they're so
wacko and they're so completely off the
charts and they're so against everything
else that is freedom oriented I mean I
just can't
yeah
see how they would appreciate that am i
naive I don't some ancestors of the Tea
Party soon for the name back this was
about actual tea in water and dressing
up and blaming it on the Indians
let's forget let's forget about that
kind of horrible pub history of the Tea
Party do i what do I think the founding
fathers would think of the tea party
yeah is that they would think that
they're crazy extremists is that they're
not about Liberty they're but they're
about small-minded narrow goals that
have anything to do with Liberty and it
just goes to show you Dana Gould make
this point one time he talks about how
they say there are ball about the Second
Amendment and if you've got to have the
Second Amendment because when the
government comes to take your freedom
you're gonna have you're gonna defend
you well the government is already
taking away all their freedoms they're
listening to all their phone calls their
tech their reading their emails they've
taken away too now they can give them
indefinite detention so they've taken
away all their Liberty and they don't
give a [ __ ] they just want their gun
still so they just want their guns they
don't care about liberty right so to
everything you just said though the
founding the founding fathers would not
that be that happy with them no that
would be I think they would be horrified
they were to hold the whole thing they
knew the tyranny of governments they
knew the tyranny of dictators that's why
they wrote the Constitution way they did
but wasn't I mean tell me it wasn't a
lot of it wasn't a lot of it about
religion initially a lot of the
Constitution a lot of the the reason
that our country was formed it wasn't a
lot of it about well it was a good is
that guy kickball the hub of the
pilgrims were so puritanical they got
kicked out of Europe for Christ's sake
that's how crazy they were right so yeah
Archon take they came here and that's
where we get this puritanical [ __ ]
right work ethic right which leads us to
work harder than anybody else in the
rest of the world without health care
right that's really we work harder I
mean part of all Chinese yes can you
believe it you have it see the videos
from the Apple factories those guys are
working pretty hard I guess it's over an
average you know I'm guessing most of
the Chinese a rural they're not working
so yeah yeah final thought is what do
you what do you think they would think
about our sort of Bush Clinton dynasty
you know I mean we've had two Bush
presidents we're probably gonna have
another
and we left yeah they just wanted to
escape kings and queens and I think
we're doing it to ourselves right here
yeah I mean it does it does seem rather
akin to that but I mean I guess the big
difference here is that they're elected
and there they were just you know kind
of appointed because of their bloodline
but doesn't like they're sort of
appointed Hilary seems like she's being
anointed well the thing is well yeah
because like I think back to what Jimmy
said it's about having money and being
able to like kind of stage a stage a
campaign where you can get yourself out
there and then I'm sure there were were
many other qualified people who aren't
able to get themselves out there and put
themselves in a position to be elected
yeah and I think that's unfortunate you
know your point about how they would
feel about to push you know 20 out of
the last 33 years a guy named Bush had a
key to the front door of the White House
yeah 20 out of the last 33 years so I
and now we're in now we're gonna have a
Clinton again so yes this this political
dynasty it's not good for America I
think that's obvious and I think they
would be horrified at that too I mean
that's
Washington left the presidency after one
term because he didn't want to have that
kind of stuff happening yeah and you
know what support Obama in 2022 that's
where this is all headed the Rubin
report brought to you by Cooper comm
they've got up to 75% off cat and dog
treats toys and more you can get another
20% off using code RR the link is right
down below click it and make your pet
happy